[Music]  i'm so honored that you've let us come  and do our show here this week and uh  frankly i'd like to give back  i wanted to give this city a special  gift  think about it philadelphia has the  rocky statue washington d.c has the  washington monument  i think now it's your turn chicago i do  as a thank you to the city  i had a sculpture made that reflects  chicago size power and beauty it is my  gift to you it's yours to have  i present to you now the chicago conan  bobblehead  [Applause]  [Music]  there it is  over 17 feet tall weighing 2 000 pounds  for no good reason it burns 600 gallons  of diesel fuel a minute  chicago it's yours and best of all we  want you to tell us where in this city  you want to see the statue stand  to do that go to teamcoco.com  coco bobble with your suggestions or  tweet them to us at hashtag cocoa bobble  you choose where to put it  and there this statue will stand  there this statue will stand  until the police make us take it down